That's why I don't understand how anybody could do like,
like ketamine,
like people that do like recreational ketamine.
Never done it.
Never done it either.
But it's scary.
You go into that k hole as they talk about what sound good Kale doesn't sound
good.
That doesn't sound good to me.
I don't want to do that.
It's some sort of animal tranquilizer,
right?
Something,
you know.
Thanks Bro.
What is it?
Um,
what's it called?
K Hole.
If it was called,
uh,
wonder lust.
If something was called wonder lost,
I'd be like,
let me try it.
Yeah,
but they call it a k hole after they've been in it.
Yeah.
It sounds horrible.
It sounds like darkness.
I don't want to go there.
I never had the desire to do something.
It was going to put you in a k hall flux.
Like acid,
not into it.
I,
we did that acid podcasts with Joey.
I didn't think I can go.
That was the only guy,
not on acid,
but Ari was on acid.
Joey Lee.
It was fucking hysterical.
I was,
I was like,
you gotta change the name.
You can't call it a hazard.
I'm not going to take anything called acid.
That fucks me up.
That's hilarious.
And He,
they should've called it something else they saw.
If they just call it Cuti love.
Yeah.
You want some QT?
Love.
Yeah.
I'll take some QT.
Love.
What's it going to do?
Oh,
just make you look at yourself.
That's funny.
Joe would drop some acid.
You don't give a fuck,
man.